let's talk about something that
potentially a lot of people have
Beaumont's actually excited about right
now and it's the share price record hi
I'm looking at potentially though the
ways in which is driving this stock
price many feeling regulation changes to
come the new administration what is your
wish list in terms of regulatory
environment changes for Goldman Sachs
well look we operate in the environment
that we have to operate in and we try to
be very adaptable and we try to risk
manager for almost any scenario when
there was massive regulatory change
after the financial crisis a lot of that
regulation came with a purpose of
creating safety and soundness in the
system and that's a really positive
thing look because it happened very
quickly there are a number of rules or a
number of things that have happened that
have an impact on certain parts of the
functioning of the banking system or
markets of the economy that with the
hindsight now you know eight or nine
years later you look at and say well
that's not optimal are the things we can
do that improve lending especially to
small businesses and mid-sized
businesses where there's growth are the
things that we can do that improve
market liquidity and so you know we're
in a position where we think it's a
great opportunity to revisit some of
these things to optimize the overall
solution for everyone without in any way
affecting safety and soundness of the
system so you do think it could breed
too much risk taking once again I I
think that a responsible and thoughtful
discussion around trying to optimize
markets access to liquidity lending
especially for small and mid-sized
businesses where there's a lot of growth
taking a look at rules where maybe in
hindsight you know you may want to
operate differently and so you know sure
we're focused on those things but
certainly not at the expense of safety
and soundness in the system let's talk
about the Goldman guys and the goldman
girls that are now in a closer proximity
to the administration we've seen I mean
nooshin just being named of course we've
got Cohen who you have now take it help
take the role of as co-ceo o'hare powell
so that there are a number of Goldman
executives now surrounding the
administration is this a positive thing
long term for Goldman Sachs because
there are some concerns being
well we've always had a culture of
public service inside Goldman Sachs and
I think that's something that we're very
proud of people have an opportunity to
work at Goldman Sachs they if they're
successful they do well and they want to
give back you know to society to the
community and so there's always been a
great culture of public service at
golden sets you know there's there's
this view that when people leave Goldman
Sachs and they go to Washington in some
way shape or form there's a lot of talk
about you know that connectivity but
I'll just tell you it's almost the
opposite you know these people have
their own reputations and they want to
in any way shape they can prove that
they're doing the right thing for the
country they want to serve and so to a
degree they're almost more careful the
other way with respect to their
connectivity so look do I think it's a
good thing for for Goldman Sachs the
culture of public service where people
at Goldman Sachs want to give back I
think is a good thing it's a good thing
for our culture I think it's a good
thing for society and I think it's great
that there are competent people like
Gary Cohn serving in Washington